From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life. I'm Emanuele Berry in for Ira Glass. So today's show starts with an email that was sent in the summer of 2020, from a man named Dr. James Whitfield. And if you remember that summer, everyone was sending out emails and tweets about race and racism in America, statements of unity from corporations. One shoe brand tweeted, "We are not asking you to buy our shoes. We are asking you to walk in someone else's."
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Emanuele Berry，代班Ira Glass。今天的节目始于2020年夏天的一封邮件，发件人是一位名叫James Whitfield博士的男士。如果你还记得那个夏天，当时每个人都在发送关于美国种族和种族主义的电子邮件和推文，企业也纷纷发表团结声明。一家鞋类品牌发推称：“我们不是要求你买我们的鞋，我们是想让你换位思考，体验别人的生活。”
Remember when everyone on Instagram posted black squares for a day to show solidarity with the Black community? I'd started to roll my eyes at all the MLK and Baldwin quotes. The murder of George Floyd had forced the country into another racial awakening.
还记得Instagram上每个人都发布了一天的黑色方块，以示对黑人社区的声援吗？我对所有关于马丁·路德·金和鲍德温的引言开始感到厌倦。乔治·弗洛伊德的谋杀案迫使整个国家进行了又一次种族觉醒。
In a school district outside Dallas, Texas, Dr. James Whitfield had just been promoted to high school principal, the school's first Black principal. And he was watching everyone send out these emails, not just corporate brands, but also his peers, other educators and administrators.
在德克萨斯州达拉斯市外的一个学区，James Whitfield博士刚被提升为高中校长，成为该校首位黑人校长。他看着每个人都在发送这些电子邮件，不仅是企业品牌，还有他的同行、其他教育工作者和行政人员。
I had been up pretty much all night, could not sleep. And I woke up at 4:30 in the morning. And I said, I have to craft something.
我几乎彻夜未眠。早上4点半醒来时，我说，我必须写点什么。
His email started by talking about the killings of George Floyd, Ahmaud Arbery, and Breonna Taylor, and how these events had brought forth the familiar enemy of racism in America. Quote, "For so long these atrocities have occurred, and we've simply moved on with our daily lives. Now it appears as though we are collectively using our voice to denounce systemic racism and the inequities that people of color face on a daily basis in our country."
他的邮件开头谈到了乔治·弗洛伊德、艾哈迈德·阿伯里和布里安娜·泰勒的遇害，以及这些事件如何让美国种族主义这个熟悉的敌人再次浮出水面。他写道：“长期以来，这些暴行一直在发生，而我们只是继续过着我们的日常生活。现在看来，我们正共同发声，谴责系统性种族主义以及有色人种在我国每天面临的不平等。”
He goes on to write from a personal perspective of a Black man who grew up in Texas. He writes, I will be 42 years old next month. And never in my life have I experienced this level of support when it comes to issues of race. I cannot begin to tell you how encouraging it has been to have so many of my white brothers and sisters buck the status quo by calling, texting, unashamedly saying that Black Lives do indeed matter. He continued--
他接着从一名在德克萨斯州长大的黑人男性的个人视角出发。他写道，下个月我就42岁了。在我的一生中，从未在种族问题上感受到如此程度的支持。我无法形容当看到我这么多白人兄弟姐妹通过打电话、发短信、毫不避讳地说出“黑人的命也是命”来挑战现状时，我感到多么受鼓舞。他继续写道——
I'm here with you to do whatever we need to do to disrupt systemic racism and eradicate it.
我愿与你们同在，共同采取我们需要采取的一切行动，去瓦解并根除系统性种族主义。
Whitfield ends his email the way he ends many of his emails and messages, by telling people he loves them dearly, which is kind of who he is, approachable, warm, a beloved figure, a cardigan-wearing dad. People appreciated the email. Parents, teachers, and students wrote to say thank you. Some said they were ready to learn more. One parent mentioned how refreshing it was to see a school leader send out this kind of letter.
Whitfield以他结尾许多邮件和信息的方式结束了这封信，告诉大家他深爱着他们。这就是他的为人：平易近人、温暖、受人爱戴，一位穿着开衫的父亲。人们很赞赏这封邮件。家长、老师和学生写信表示感谢。有人说他们准备好了解更多了。一位家长提到，看到一位学校领导发出这样的信是多么令人耳目一新。
A year passed, Whitfield's first year as principal. And it's a tough one because, you know, the pandemic. But he made it through. And then he arrived at the summer of 2021. It is a very different landscape from the summer of 2020. In fact, the script has flipped. Public conversations have moved from let's all try and understand and talk about systemic racism to let's never mention systemic racism.
一年过去了，这是Whitfield担任校长的第一年。因为疫情，这一年很艰难。但他挺过来了。接着到了2021年的夏天。与2020年夏天相比，环境截然不同。事实上，剧本翻转了。公众讨论从“让我们努力理解并谈论系统性种族主义”变成了“绝不要提及系统性种族主义”。
This is especially true in Texas, where Dr. Whitfield is. In Texas, the conversation is suddenly all about banning critical race theory. Critical Race Theory, CRT, you've probably heard about it. It's a way to chart how racism is ingrained in the American legal system and other institutions. But at this moment, CRT has become kind of a boogeyman, a quick shorthand to shut down anything acknowledging racism or even Blackness.
在Whitfield博士所在的德克萨斯州尤其如此。在德克萨斯州，对话突然全部变成了禁止批判性种族理论（CRT）。你可能听说过CRT。这是一种揭示种族主义如何根植于美国法律制度及其他机构的方式。但在此时，CRT已成为一种“稻草人”，成为打压任何承认种族主义甚至黑人身份的快速借口。
Texas passed a law in 2021 banning CRT in schools. And during the school year, Dr. Whitfield heard that some people were grumbling about him on social media, saying he was a race warrior. The online grumblings became public at a school board meeting in July, when a resident points to Whitfield's email, his email where he basically says it seems like we're ready to talk about race as a country. He points to that email as proof that he is indoctrinating students with critical race theory.
德克萨斯州在2021年通过了一项法律，禁止在学校传授CRT。在那个学年里，Whitfield博士听说有人在社交媒体上抱怨他，说他是“种族战士”。这种网络抱怨在7月的校董会会议上公开了，当时一名居民指向Whitfield的邮件——那封他基本上表达了“作为国家我们似乎准备好谈论种族问题了”的邮件——将其作为他正在向学生灌输批判性种族理论的证据。
Tonight I would like to express my concerns, not only of myself, but of many in our community, about the implementation of critical race theory in our district, specifically the views and goals of the principal of Colleyville Heritage High School, James Whitfield. I was first made aware of Mr Whitfield's extreme views on race when a concerned friend of mine shared with me a letter he sent to parents and students in the summer of 2020.
今晚，我不仅代表我自己，也代表社区中的许多人，表达我们对本学区实施批判性种族理论的担忧，特别是关于Colleyville Heritage高中校长James Whitfield的观点和目标。我是通过一位关心此事的友人在2020年夏天分享给我的一封他发给家长和学生的信，才了解到Whitfield先生在种族问题上的极端观点。
To be clear, Dr. Whitfield is not teaching CRT. He didn't propose educational reforms in his email. He wasn't reshaping the curriculum. He did support an existing program at the school that tried to get kids into college who wouldn't traditionally go. He got flak for that. But the program predated him.
需要明确的是，Whitfield博士并没有教授CRT。他在邮件中没有提出教育改革建议。他也没有重塑课程。他确实支持学校内一个现有的旨在帮助那些传统上无法进入大学的孩子升学的项目。他因此受到了抨击。但该项目在他任职前就已经存在了。
People complained about an approving mention of the Southern Poverty Law Center, but also that he quoted Gil Scott-Heron in an email saying, "The revolution will not be televised." And, of course, that email from 2020 where, like everyone else in 2020, he denounces systemic racism.
人们抱怨他赞许地提到了南方贫困法律中心，还因为他在邮件中引用了吉尔·斯科特-赫伦的话说“革命不会被电视转播”。当然，还有那封2020年的邮件，在那封信里，像2020年的其他人一样，他谴责了系统性种族主义。
Later in this letter, he goes further.
在这封信的后面，他进一步写道。
Mr. [INAUDIBLE], Mr. Clark.
[听不清]先生，Clark先生。
Yes.
是。
We really prefer that you don't criticize a particular employee of the district.
我们真的希望您不要批评本学区的特定员工。
OK.
好的。
If you have any issues, we--
如果你有什么问题，我们……
How about you fire that clown? How's that--
你干脆开除那个小丑怎么样？
Sir--
先生……
Mr.--
How about you fire that--
开除那个……怎么样？
Hey, keep it down!
嘿，安静点！
Sir.
先生。
At the time, it seemed absurd that this would actually happen, that Dr. Whitfield would be fired. A handful of people at a board meeting demanding a respected and newly hired principal be fired for promoting an academic theory he wasn't promoting, that seemed hard to imagine. But over the next few months, that is what happened.
当时，这看起来荒谬至极，Whitfield博士竟然真的会被解雇。在校董会上，几个人要求解雇一位受人尊敬且新聘的校长，理由是他推广了一项他并未推广的学术理论，这似乎很难想象。但在接下来的几个月里，事情真的就这样发生了。
In August, the board placed Dr. Whitfield on paid administrative leave but didn't give a reason why. He talked to the media about it. In September, Dr. Whitfield defended himself at a board meeting. One of the items on the agenda was should the district renew Whitfield's contract for the next year. Whitfield showed up for the public comments and, like everyone else, he got one minute to speak.
8月，校董会让Whitfield博士带薪行政休假，但没有给出原因。他向媒体谈到了这件事。9月，Whitfield博士在校董会上为自己辩护。会议议程之一是学区是否应续签Whitfield下一年的合同。Whitfield出席了公众意见环节，和所有人一样，他有一分钟发言时间。
Hello, I'm Dr. James Whitfield. Dr. Ryan, board of trustees, I first want to express my gratitude for all the love, support, and encouragement from the community, especially our students who have regretfully been criticized for their speaking up in this matter.
大家好，我是James Whitfield博士。Ryan博士，各位董事会成员，首先我想对社区表达我的感激，感谢你们的爱、支持和鼓励，特别是我们的学生，他们因为在此事上发声而遗憾地受到了批评。
I stand before you today no different than I was when I came in in '18-'19.
我今天站在这里，与我在18-19学年刚入职时没有任何不同。
The 2018-2019 school year, when he was first hired by the district.
2018-2019学年，那是他最初被学区聘用的时候。
I'm an advocate for all kids. I believe every student, regardless of race, religion, sexual orientation, whatever bucket you want to put them in, I believe they all have access to-- they should have access to excellent, equitable education. Yes, I said those words.
我是所有孩子的倡导者。我相信每一位学生，无论种族、宗教、性取向，无论你想把他们归入哪一类，我都相信他们都能获得——他们应该获得优秀、公平的教育。是的，我说了这些话。
Unfortunately, my unapologetic stance for those things has brought us here tonight, which is disheartening. The attacks from people outside is one thing, but the outright silence and direct actions taken towards me by GSD leadership team-- GCIC leadership team, sorry, I'm trying to get this in-- was absolutely heartbreaking. I can assure you, I have not changed. I'm still the same man today as when you hired me in '18-'19. You promoted me twice in three years. So I ask you what has changed since July 26--
不幸的是，我对这些事物的毫不妥协的立场让我们今晚走到了这一步，这令人沮丧。外界的攻击是一回事，但GCIC领导团队——抱歉，我正在努力说出来——对我的彻底沉默和直接行动让我感到无比心碎。我可以向你们保证，我没有改变。我和你们在18-19年聘用我时是同一个人。你们三年内提拔了我两次。所以我问你们，自7月26日以来发生了什么变化——
Thank you, Dr. Whitfield.
谢谢你，Whitfield博士。
Dr. Ryan.
Ryan博士。
[SCATTERED CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[零星的欢呼和掌声]
Excuse me, please. Sir--
打扰一下，请。先生……
Thank you, Dr. Whitfield.
谢谢你，Whitfield博士。
The board's response, they vote not to renew his contract. I reached out to the district, and they said they were not going to talk about this. But in public statements they made earlier, they said the decision was not based on people calling for Dr. Whitfield to be fired. They list a bunch of other reasons, stuff like insubordination. A Facebook post he wrote defending himself was not OK with them, against professional conduct. He talked to the media instead of filing formal complaints with the school.
董事会的决定是投票决定不续签他的合同。我联系了学区，他们表示对此事不予置评。但在早些时候发表的公开声明中，他们称该决定并非基于人们要求解雇Whitfield博士。他们列举了一堆其他原因，比如抗命。他为了自辩写的一篇Facebook帖子让他们觉得不妥，认为违反了职业操守。他向媒体谈论了此事，而不是向学校提交正式投诉。
As they read this list at the meeting, you could hear students and parents who came to support Whitfield scoff at the items being read.
当他们在会上宣读这份清单时，你可以听到支持Whitfield的学生和家长对所读的内容发出冷笑。
The fifth reason for the recommendation, Dr. Whitfield has diminished his effectiveness by dividing large sections of the community by continuing to raise--
推荐的第五个理由是，Whitfield博士通过继续提出……分裂了大部分社区，从而降低了他的效力……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Come on.
算了吧。
Are you kidding?
你在开玩笑吗？
Wow.
哇。
Please stay quiet.
请保持安静。
The response went on for so long she never got to finish the statement.
这种反应持续了太久，她甚至没能读完这份声明。
Please be quiet.
请安静。
It said he was dividing large sections of the community by, quote, "continuing to raise issues of critical race theory." Doctor Whitfield lost his job. What changed over the last year? As Whitfield said, not him. That email didn't change. The black squares are gone from Instagram. The random reparations money from friends, gone. We went from anti-racist books crowding the bestsellers list to banning kids' books about Rosa Parks.
文中称，他通过“继续提出批判性种族理论的问题”而分裂了大部分社区。Whitfield博士失去了工作。过去一年发生了什么变化？正如Whitfield所说，不是他。那封邮件没变。Instagram上的黑色方块不见了。朋友们随机提供的赔偿金没了。我们从反种族主义书籍挤满畅销书榜单，变成了禁掉关于罗莎·帕克斯的童书。
For Dr. Whitfield, the consequence of getting caught in this backlash is he's no longer in the one place he really wants to be. When I spoke with him in early November, he told me he was still dropping his kid off at elementary school. The high school is across the street.
对Whitfield博士来说，陷入这场反弹的后果是他无法再留在那个他真正想待的地方了。11月初我与他交谈时，他说他仍在送孩子去小学。高中就在马路对面。
Oh, I mean, I look over there every-- I can't just not look, right? My wife is just like, well, just try to look the other way. And I can't. You know, as I'm driving by, you can see down one of the main hallways, right? There's these big windows, and you can see right down the hallway.
哦，我的意思是，我每次……我无法不去看不看，对吧？我妻子总是说，好吧，试着往别处看。但我做不到。你知道，当我开车经过时，你可以看到其中一条主要走廊，对吧？那里有很大的窗户，可以直接看进走廊里。
And so, as I'm walking by, I'm envisioning the different classrooms and the teachers that I would check on every morning. And it's three stories, and so by the time the first bell had rung, I was already at 10,000 steps because I'm running around this place, checking in on teachers. And so, I think about that every morning.
所以，当我走过时，我脑海中会浮现出我每天早上都会检查的那些教室和老师。那是三层楼高的建筑，所以当第一声铃响时，我已经走了10,000步了，因为我在那里跑来跑去，查看老师们的情况。所以，我每天早上都会想到这一点。
And so, yeah, it's really hard to pass by a place that you love and know that there's staff members that you love in there. There's students that you love in there. And you know that's where you're supposed to be. But you're not allowed to be in there, right? It's like, what kind of person is not allowed to be in there? You know, it's disheartening.
所以，是的，要经过一个你热爱的、并且知道里面有你热爱的员工的地方，真的很艰难。那里有你热爱的学生。你知道那才是你应该待的地方。但你不被允许进入，对吧？这就像是，什么样的人是不被允许待在那里的呢？你知道，这真令人沮丧。
The line of what's acceptable to say about race and racism in America, it moved. It's as though we were having one argument, and then the terms changed. And that shift has left many Black people exposed and vulnerable and living with those consequences.
关于美国种族和种族主义的言论底线，它变了。就好像我们原本在进行一场争论，然后规则变了。而那种转变使许多黑人处于暴露和脆弱的境地，并不得不承受这些后果。
This backlash, it's not surprising. This is what America does, Reconstruction, then Jim Crow, the Civil Rights movement, to the war on drugs, Obama to Trump. So no, it's not surprising that there is backlash.
这种反弹并不令人惊讶。这就是美国所做的：重建时期，然后是吉姆·克劳法，民权运动，毒品战争，奥巴马到特朗普。所以不，有反弹并不令人惊讶。
But what I am surprised by is the way people have been caught up and tangled in it, the choices they've made to either further twist themselves along the line of what's acceptable or move away from it, the way Black people have had to reconsider what to say, and the fallout that comes with those choices.
但我感到惊讶的是人们被卷入其中的方式，他们为了让自己在可接受的范围内进一步扭曲，或者试图远离这一事实而做出的选择，黑人不得不重新考虑该说些什么，以及这些选择所带来的后果。
Our show today, two stories of people trying to figure out what to say or if they should say anything in this moment of backlash. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目，讲述了两个人在这种反弹时刻试图弄清楚该说什么，或者是否应该说什么的故事。请继续关注。
Act 1, Incident. The place that this backlash is playing out most dramatically is in schools, in particular, school board meetings. So I spent a lot of time watching heated school board meetings this year. Sometimes parents are angry about something as small as the email Dr. Whitfield wrote, or a specific book they don't like, or an effort to diversify a library's collection. Sometimes it's a new resolution to promote equity in the school.
第一幕，事件。这种反弹最戏剧性地发生在学校，特别是学校董事会会议上。所以我今年花了很多时间观看激烈的校董会会议。有时家长们对像Whitfield博士写的那封邮件这样的小事，或者他们不喜欢的一本书，或者图书馆多元化馆藏的努力感到愤怒。有时是关于在学校促进公平的新决议。
And a lot of these parents repeat the same talking points in these meetings across the country. They say microaggressions are not real. What about reverse racism? And somehow, Martin Luther King, Jr. comes up a lot. But what these examples boil down to is we shouldn't be talking about racism because it's not a thing anymore.
这些家长中有很多在全国各地的会议上重复着同样的论点。他们说微歧视不是真的。那“反向种族歧视”呢？不知何故，马丁·路德·金总是被提及。但这些例子归根结底就是我们不应该谈论种族主义，因为它已经不存在了。
First thing I want to say, and it's a fact that Traverse City is not a racist city. And the US is definitely not a racist nation.
首先我想说的是，特拉弗斯城不是一个种族主义城市，这是一个事实。而美国绝对不是一个种族主义国家。
This is from Traverse City, Michigan.
这是来自密歇根州特拉弗斯城。
This thing about this racism, we have been marching away from racism by leaps and bounds for decades upon decades.
关于种族主义这件事，几十年来我们一直在跨越式地远离种族主义。
I keep wondering what is it like to be a kid in one of these towns, for kids of color, especially, when some adults are saying racism is a problem and other adults are saying it's not one at all. For instance, the meeting you just heard from Traverse City, what's so remarkable about this particular meeting is that what these parents are partially responding to is a clearly racist incident in their schools.
我一直想知道，在这些城镇里，作为一个孩子，特别是对于有色人种的孩子来说，当一些成年人说种族主义是个问题，而另一些成年人却说根本不是问题时，那是什么感觉。例如，你刚才听到的那场特拉弗斯城的会议，这场特定会议最引人注目的是，这些家长们部分是在回应学校里一起明显的种族主义事件。
I've been talking to a kid who was targeted in that incident, a 16-year-old Black biracial girl named Nevaeh, about what had happened to her. And her story is so much more personal and immediate than what you get from any of these meetings. A quick warning, this story might not be appropriate for kids. Here it is, Act 1.
我一直在和那个事件中的目标人物交谈，一个16岁的黑人混血女孩，名叫Nevaeh，谈论发生在她身上的事。她的故事比你在这些会议上听到的任何东西都要个人化、更直接。一个小警告，这个故事可能不适合儿童。这就是第一幕。
A year ago, Nevaeh was a sophomore in high school who didn't think about her Blackness too much. Yes, she lives in a mostly white town, 90% white. And yes, she's often the only person of color in a given room, including her family. She's adopted. They're white. But her journals were not filled with tragic Black-girl-in-white-town clichés. She was writing fiction, fantasy, young adult, romance.
一年前，Nevaeh是一名高中二年级学生，她并没有过多考虑自己的黑人身份。是的，她住在一个大部分是白人的城镇，90%是白人。是的，她通常是房间里唯一的有色人种，包括在家里。她是领养的，养父母是白人。但她的日记里并没有填满悲惨的“白人小镇里的黑人女孩”的陈词滥调。她在写小说，奇幻、青少年读物、浪漫小说。
I love fiction writing more than anything. I could not write poetry or nonfiction. And then, I'm also really interested in psychology. I've taken that class for-- I'm on my second year taking it now. I find it really interesting.
比起任何东西，我更喜欢写虚构作品。我写不了诗或纪实文学。而且，我对心理学也非常感兴趣。我已经上那门课……我现在是第二年选修了。我觉得它非常有趣。
When you say psychology, what is it about psychology that you're interested in?
当你提到心理学时，你对心理学的什么感兴趣？
I love learning about why people act the way they do in certain situations. Like, the brain is cool, but I'm more onto, like, the behavioral aspect of psychology
我喜欢了解为什么人们在特定情况下会有那样的行为。比如，大脑很酷，但我更倾向于心理学的行为方面。
Nevaeh is a self-proclaimed overthinker. And she does this thing, when you talk with her, that makes her feel both mature and young at the same time. It's that, when she doesn't know something, she says she doesn't know it with such confidence that you feel assured that someday she will know that thing. A year ago, Nevaeh would have described her high school and her experience there as typical.
Nevaeh自称是个想得太多的人。当你和她交谈时，她表现出一种既成熟又年轻的感觉。这就是，当她不知道某件事时，她说她不知道时充满了自信，让你确信总有一天她会弄懂那件事。一年前，Nevaeh会形容她的高中生活和她在那里的经历是典型的。
I mean, like, there are groups here and there. But it's not like the, oh, you can't sit with us, you're not that type of person.
我的意思是，到处都有小圈子。但这不像那种，哦，你不能和我们坐在一起，你不是那类人。
It's not Mean Girls situation.
这不是《贱女孩》的情况。
No, it's not. It's not like that at all.
不，不是。根本不像那样。
Nevaeh had a lot of friends. She wove in and out of a bunch of different groups at school. And then she had her inner circle. One of her closest friends in that circle, someone she talked to daily, I'll call Katie.
Nevaeh有很多朋友。她在学校里穿梭于许多不同的圈子中。然后她有自己的核心圈子。那个圈子里她最亲密的朋友之一，一个她每天都交谈的人，我称她为Katie。
We met in seventh grade, and we went to the same school for seventh and eighth grade. And so we were really close. And then ninth grade came along, and I moved schools. But we still kept in contact and we still talked all the time.
我们在七年级认识，七年级和八年级去了同一所学校。所以我们非常亲密。后来到了九年级，我转学了。但我们仍然保持联系，而且我们一直都在交谈。
During the pandemic, they would sit on FaceTime together and hang out. Katie was a person who could talk Nevaeh down when she was stressed, especially about school. They were also goofballs together. They'd go to the mall just to try on outrageous outfits and crack each other up.
疫情期间，她们会一起坐在FaceTime上聊天。Katie是那种能在Nevaeh有压力时安抚她的人，特别是在学习上。她们在一起时也是活宝。她们会去购物中心试穿离谱的衣服，然后把对方逗得大笑。
The racist thing that happened to Nevaeh, the thing that led to those heated school board meetings, that happened in the spring of 2021. And it started with a text from Katie.
发生在Nevaeh身上的种族主义事件，那件导致那些激烈校董会会议的事情，发生在2021年春天。它始于Katie发来的一条短信。
And just said that she was in this really, like, messed up group chat with her friends. It was late at night and I was tired, so I didn't really like-- I was like, oh, OK, if it's really that bad, you should leave. I'm going to go to bed.
她只是说她在一个非常糟糕的群聊里，和她的朋友们一起。那时很晚了，我很累，所以我没太……我说，哦，好吧，如果真的那么糟糕，你应该退出。我要去睡觉了。
Nevaeh wasn't really sure what Katie was talking about, so she brushed it off. She woke up the next morning to more messages from Katie about what happened in the group chat.
Nevaeh不太确定Katie在说什么，所以她没在意。第二天早上醒来，她收到了更多来自Katie关于那个群聊发生了什么的短信。
She texted me and she was like, hey, you were in it. And I was like, oh, I was in it? What's it about? And then she told me. She was just like, oh, they're, like, bad stuff. They're selling, like, people. And I was like, oh.
她给我发短信说，嘿，你在里面。我说，哦，我在里面？那是关于什么的？然后她告诉了我。她只是说，哦，他们在卖人，之类坏事。我说，哦。
The group chat was called Slave Trade, with two purple devil emojis. It's about half a dozen mostly white students listing their Black classmates for sale, posting their pictures and throwing out bids as if they're in an auction, like, a slave auction. Apparently, Nevaeh was one of the people in the chat who was, quote, unquote, "put up for sale."
那个群聊的名字叫“奴隶贸易”，后面跟着两个紫色恶魔表情符号。大约有六个大部分是白人的学生，列出了他们的黑人同学进行出售，发布他们的照片并进行竞价，就像在拍卖会上一样，就像奴隶拍卖。显然，Nevaeh是群里被“挂牌出售”的人之一。
My first reaction was how much did I go for and who did I go to? Full honesty there. And she said that I went to her for free.
我的第一反应是我卖了多少钱，卖给了谁？说实话。她说我被免费卖给了她。
The chat is essentially a private text thread that after some time disappears, a feature of the Snapchat app. Some students tell the school district about the chat. The school calls Nevaeh's mom and the parents of other students. And it's while her mom's on the phone with the school that it all starts to sink in.
那个群聊本质上是一个私人短信串，过一段时间就会消失，这是Snapchat应用程序的一个功能。一些学生把那个群聊告诉了学校。学校给Nevaeh的妈妈和其他学生的家长打了电话。就在她妈妈和学校通电话时，一切开始显现了。
And at that point, I was like, oh, I was sold. I don't know how bad that is, but I assume it's not the best. And so then I asked my friend to give me screenshots. And she did.
那时，我想，哦，我被卖了。我不知道这有多糟糕，但我认为这肯定不是最好的。所以我就请朋友给我截图。她照做了。
This is what they say. First screenshot, one student, "What up, niggas. New group chat for making fun of Black people." In reply, "Very nice." Another screenshot, "All Blacks should die. Let's have another Holocaust." "Yay," someone cheers. "I concur," says another.
他们是这样说的。第一张截图，一个学生写道：“嘿，黑鬼们。建立新群聊来嘲笑黑人。”回复：“非常好。”另一张截图，“所有黑人都应该死。让我们再来一次大屠杀。”“耶，”有人欢呼。“我同意，”另一个人说。
Picture of a Black kid. "Homo goes for $50. Man's sus. He comes as a bonus. He's free." Someone else adds, "Man so gay, I'll kill him for Jesus." Another screenshot, picture of another Black student, "Negative $10 for autism," someone says. "50% off sale."
一张黑人孩子的照片。“那个同性恋卖50美元。那家伙真可疑。他还是个赠品，他是免费的。”另一个人补充说，“那家伙太同性恋了，我会为了耶稣杀了他。”另一张截图，另一名黑人学生的照片，“因为患有自闭症减10美元，”有人说。“五折大甩卖。”
Picture of two black teenagers. Someone says, "They can run, but they can't hide. $100 each, double the trouble. They like picking cotton." Someone makes an offer. "I'll take them for $150 as the pair."
两名黑人青少年的照片。有人说，“他们能跑，但躲不掉。每人100美元，双倍麻烦。他们喜欢摘棉花。”有人出价。“我出150美元包下这一对。”
Another screenshot, picture of Nevaeh. She's in a red crop top and jeans and a hat, posing near a tree. Written underneath, "Starting bid, $100." "Ew," someone comments. Another "ew." Followed by another.
另一张截图，Nevaeh的照片。她穿着红色短款上衣和牛仔裤，戴着帽子，在一棵树旁摆姿势。下面写着，“起拍价100美元。”“呕，”有人评论道。另一个“呕”。接着又是另一个。
And then just, then and there, everything hit. I was disgusted to the gut. It was just, like, oh, my gosh. I joked with these students before. I couldn't believe that they would think of typing something that they thought like it would be OK. After, like, everything with Black Lives Matter this last year, it was just like, wow, OK. It showed me the type of person they were.
那一刻，一切都击中了心头。我感到胃里一阵翻江倒海。我简直不敢相信他们竟然会想到输入一些他们认为可以接受的东西。在过去一年“黑人的命也是命”运动之后，这简直就像是，哇，好吧。它向我展示了他们是什么样的人。
It's almost like Nevaeh's inside the darker, not funny version of that Eddie Murphy skit. Maybe you've seen it. The one where he goes undercover as a white man and discovers all the things white people do when there aren't Black people in the room.
这几乎就像Nevaeh处于那个艾迪·墨菲小品中更黑暗、不那么搞笑的版本里。也许你看过那个小品。那个他伪装成白人，发现当没有黑人在房间时白人会做所有事情的小品。
She had a new window into who her classmates were in private, in these screenshots. It was the spring of 2021. Luckily, she was in remote school. She wouldn't have to face them until her junior year started in the fall.
通过这些截图，她有了新的窗口去了解她的同学们在私底下是什么样的人。那是2021年的春天。幸运的是，她当时在上网课。直到秋季高三开始，她都不必面对他们。
Nevaeh's mom, Jala, saw the screenshots and the words "all Blacks should die" and worried for Nevaeh's safety. She emailed all the school board members, went back and forth with school administrators. She felt like no one was taking it seriously. She called the police.
Nevaeh的妈妈Jala看到了截图和“所有黑人都应该死”这些字眼，为Nevaeh的安全感到担忧。她给所有校董会成员发了邮件，并与学校行政人员反复沟通。她觉得没有人认真对待这件事。她报了警。
The police investigated the group chat. A few weeks later they told Jala that there were no chargeable offenses. Jala's confused.
警方调查了那个群聊。几周后，他们告诉Jala，没有可控诉的违法行为。Jala很困惑。
I said that doesn't make any sense because there was talks of killing all Black kids and starting another Holocaust. To me, that was a direct-- indirect threat of something that could potentially happen. And he just disregarded it as kids being kids and talking smack.
我说那根本说不通，因为里面提到了杀掉所有黑人孩子并开始另一场大屠杀。对我来说，那是潜在可能发生的直接威胁。但他只是把这视为孩子们只是孩子，在说废话。
The school gets back to Jala and Nevaeh about how they will handle the Snapchat incident. Ultimately, they say they will follow the district's policy for discipline, but they couldn't say specifically what that meant.
学校回电给Jala和Nevaeh，告知他们将如何处理Snapchat事件。最终，他们表示将遵循学区的纪律政策，但无法具体说明那意味着什么。
Nevaeh was worried. It seemed like the whole thing was just going to be swept under the rug. And she wanted people to know what happened. She hadn't done anything to be a part of the Snapchat except be Black. Should she speak up? But she worried over that too. If I say something, will people think I'm overreacting? But if I don't say anything, will anyone else even know about this?
Nevaeh很担心。整件事似乎只是要被扫地出门。她想让人知道发生了什么。除了身为黑人，她什么都没做就卷入了那个Snapchat事件。她应该说出来吗？但她也为此感到烦恼。如果我说出来，人们会觉得我反应过度吗？但如果我不说什么，还有人会知道这件事吗？
In the end, Nevaeh made the decision to speak. She talked to the press about what happened. Instead of disappearing, the story of mostly white high schoolers auctioning off their Black classmates in a secret slave auction, it got a lot of attention.
最终，Nevaeh决定发声。她向媒体讲述了发生的事情。这个故事——关于大部分是白人的高中生在一场秘密奴隶拍卖中拍卖他们的黑人同学——不仅没有消失，反而获得了大量的关注。
At first, Nevaeh felt good talking about it. She got a lot of support. People reached out. She felt a sense of relief. But just as quickly, as is happening in many parts of America, talking about racism in Traverse City led to backlash. Nevaeh speaking up set off other, bigger conversations about racism in the community, which led to that heated school board meeting where some adults insisted Traverse City is not a racist place and that any discussion of racism causes division.
起初，Nevaeh谈论这件事时感觉很好。她得到了很多支持。人们纷纷联系她。她感到一种解脱。但正如美国许多地方正在发生的那样，谈论特拉弗斯城的种族主义引发了反弹。Nevaeh的发声引发了关于社区内种族主义的其他、更大的对话，这导致了那场激烈的校董会会议，一些成年人坚称特拉弗斯城不是一个种族主义地方，任何关于种族主义的讨论都会导致分裂。
But something that was more important to Nevaeh was the backlash she got from her peers. Some kids started to get tired of seeing Nevaeh on the news. And to Nevaeh, it seemed almost irritated. She noticed a gradual change, even among some of her friends.
但对Nevaeh更重要的是她从同龄人那里受到的反弹。一些孩子开始厌倦在新闻上看到Nevaeh。对Nevaeh来说，这看起来几乎是愤怒。她注意到了一种逐渐的变化，甚至在她的一些朋友中也是如此。
They've always been nice, and I've always hung out with them a lot. And I thought that we kind of had the same viewpoint and opinions on a lot of things. And so then when this whole thing happened and they started to say, oh, why are people still talking about it, why is it such a big deal, that really showed me, like, oh, we disagree on such a big topic here, like racism. Where do they stand? And should I let something like this determine my friendship with someone or not?
他们一直都很友好，我一直和他们在一起玩。我觉得我们在很多事情上有着相同的观点和看法。所以当整件事发生后，他们开始说，哦，为什么人们还在谈论它，为什么这算大事，这真的向我展示了，哦，我们在这样一个大话题上存在分歧，比如种族主义。他们的立场是什么？我应该让这样的事情决定我和某人的友谊吗？
This question, where do the people around me stand, it was a question that kept coming up again and again and again as the summer passed and the school year approached.
这个问题——我周围的人立场是什么——是一个随着夏天过去、新学年临近而不断出现的问题。
In the fall, she went back to school in person for the first time since the incident. Nevaeh's a junior. She looked around and wondered, who are my friends? Who can I trust? Who thinks it's OK I was sold in a slave trade? Nevaeh thinks to herself, I can be friends with anybody.
秋天，她自事件发生后第一次回到学校面对面授课。Nevaeh是一名高三学生。她环顾四周，心想，谁是我的朋友？我可以信任谁？谁认为我被卖进奴隶贸易是没关系的？Nevaeh心想，我可以和任何人做朋友。
One of the kids who participated in the Snapchat slave trade, I'll call him Luke, they were texting right after the incident and again just before school started. The text said--
其中一个参与了Snapchat奴隶贸易的孩子，我称他为Luke，他们在事件发生后立即发了短信，并在开学前又发了一次。短信写着——
Like, oh my gosh, I'm so sorry, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then I've had other students come up to me and be like, he's really sorry. He is scared of you now. He is--
比如，哦天哪，我太抱歉了，等等等等。然后我有其他同学过来跟我说，他真的很抱歉。他现在很怕你。他……
Good.
很好。
Yeah, he's scared of me now. The second time he sent me an apology, he was like, oh, I want to be friends with you again. And I was like, OK. I'm cool with being friends with anybody.
是的，他现在怕我了。他第二次给我道歉时说，哦，我想再次和你做朋友。我说，好吧。我愿意和任何人做朋友。
They texted a little, but it wasn't the same. Luke's a chatterbox and a jokester, Nevaeh says. They were old friends. They've known each other since middle school. But she couldn't talk to Luke about what happened. It seemed like he just wanted to move past it without ever addressing it.
她们发了一点短信，但感觉不一样了。Luke是个话痨和爱开玩笑的人，Nevaeh说。她们是老朋友了。她们从初中就认识了。但她无法和Luke谈论发生了什么。他似乎只是想跳过这件事，而不去正面解决它。
And then it just got weird because it felt like-- I mean, there was something we couldn't discuss between each other. And it was a thick line between us that was just kind of awkward. And so I just stopped talking to him.
然后事情就变得很奇怪，因为感觉——我的意思是，有些事情是我们之间无法讨论的。我们之间有一条厚厚的界限，让人感到尴尬。所以我停止和他说话了。
Luke was the first friend Nevaeh was forced to make a decision about. Maybe she couldn't be friends with everyone. As the weeks passed, she started ignoring him. Like, if she sees him in the halls, she'd look at her phone, walk to the other side. Staying away from Luke meant she distanced herself from other friends, like her one friend I'll call Leah.
Luke是第一个Nevaeh被迫做出决定的朋友。也许她不能和每个人都做朋友。随着几周过去，她开始忽略他。比如，如果在走廊看到他，她会看手机，走到另一边。远离Luke意味着她疏远了其他朋友，比如我的一个朋友，我称她为Leah。
She was like, hey, I know how wrong, like, what he did. But I am friends with him. And I told her, hey, I'm not going to be the one to tell you who you can and cannot be friends with. If you want to be friends with him, you can be friends with him.
她说，嘿，我知道他做的事有多错。但我还是他的朋友。我告诉她，嘿，我不会告诉你可以和谁做朋友，不可以和谁做朋友。如果你想和他做朋友，你可以和他做朋友。
And I've just been like, hey, but if you are friends with him, you have to understand and consider the fact that I'm not going to be around as much. Like, I'm not going to hang out with him when you're hanging out with-- I'm not going to hang out with him at all, in general. I think it's just hard for her to like, I guess, let him go.
我只是说，嘿，但如果你和他做朋友，你必须理解并考虑到这样一个事实，那就是我不会再像以前那样频繁出现。比如，当你在和他在一起时，我不会参与其中……总的来说，我根本不会和他在一起玩。我觉得对她来说，要放下他可能很难。
So Nevaeh tries to navigate this new social landscape on her own. But it's not simple. Take this one time a couple of months ago. Nevaeh was meeting Leah at a football game. She got to the stands and Luke was there. Nevaeh had no idea he would be there.
所以Nevaeh试图独自应对这种新的社交环境。但这并不简单。以几个月前的一次经历为例。Nevaeh约了Leah在足球比赛上见面。她走到看台上，Luke也在那儿。Nevaeh根本不知道他会在那儿。
I'm not going to be a baby about this. I can be mature. And I don't have to speak to him. I'm not going to make a big deal out of this. So then I was just like, OK, I want to watch the game, so I'll stay.
我不会因为这件事表现得像个孩子。我可以成熟一点。而且我不必和他说话。我不会把这事闹大。所以我就想，好吧，我想看比赛，所以我留下。
The game started. Leah called a player trash for making a bad play. Then Luke, who was behind Nevaeh with his buddies, defends the player, mocks the girl who shouted, calling her mean, telling her he'd never say something so mean. It rung in Nevaeh's ears.
比赛开始了。Leah因为一名球员的糟糕表现说他是垃圾。然后Luke，他带着他的伙伴在Nevaeh身后，为那名球员辩护，嘲笑大喊的女孩，称她刻薄，告诉她他永远不会说那么刻薄的话。这在Nevaeh的耳中回响。
And then I just, like, I stopped and I turned around, and I was like, really? And then he looked at me and his mouth just dropped open. And then his friends started like, Nevaeh, Naveah, you don't need to bring that up. Come on. No, no thank you. He's already been through enough.
然后我停了下来，转身说，真的吗？他看着我，嘴巴张开了。然后他的朋友们开始说，Nevaeh，Nevaeh，你没必要提那件事。算了吧。不，不，谢谢。他已经受够了。
Nevaeh I didn't want to cause trouble for Luke. She wished him well. She just couldn't pretend that nothing happened. And she couldn't stop questioning a lot of her relationships, even her relationship with Katie.
Nevaeh不想给Luke惹麻烦。她祝他一切顺利。她只是无法假装什么都没发生。她无法停止质疑很多关系，甚至是她和Katie的关系。
It was never clear to Nevaeh if Katie had participated in the chat. They were friends. Katie is the one who told her about the chat. It didn't make sense that she would have joined in. But Katie had said she'd bought Nevaeh for free. That detail stuck with Nevaeh. Then she started to hear from other people that Katie had said stuff. Was that true?
Nevaeh一直不清楚Katie是否参与了那个群聊。她们是朋友。Katie是那个告诉她有群聊的人。她参与其中并不合理。但Katie曾说她把Nevaeh免费买了。这个细节困扰着Nevaeh。然后她开始从别人那里听到Katie说了些什么。那是真的吗？
The screenshots Katie sent Nevaeh didn't have the full conversation. In the screenshots she does have, Katie says nothing. Was it possible there was something in the missing parts of the chat?
Katie发给Nevaeh的截图并没有完整的对话。在她拥有的截图中，Katie什么都没说。是否有可能是聊天的缺失部分里有东西？
Nevaeh wondered, did she laugh at me? Did she place any bids? No, she probably stayed quiet, didn't say anything. She's the reason I even know what happened. Nevaeh was scared to ask her, so she didn't. They continued to be friends, but the uncertainty weighed on Nevaeh.
Nevaeh心想，她嘲笑我了吗？她参与竞价了吗？不，她可能保持沉默，什么也没说。她是让我知道发生了什么的人。Nevaeh害怕问她，所以她没问。她们继续做朋友，但这种不确定性困扰着Nevaeh。
As much as I'd like to think she wasn't the type of person to do this, all of these people who were in the group chat were her friends. She hung out with them every day. She was surrounded by them all the time. She FaceTimed them. She joked with them all the time. And they made jokes like these all the time.
虽然我很想认为她不是那种会这样做的人，但群聊里的所有人都是她的朋友。她每天都和他们混在一起。她一直和他们在一起。她和他们FaceTime。她一直和他们开玩笑。他们一直开这类玩笑。
The guy who started it, that was his personality. He was just a rude, racist person. And so, if she's surrounding herself with such rude, racist people like that, eventually, she's going to adapt that and adopt that kind of behavior. I mean, I learned it in psychology, so--
那个发起这件事的家伙，那是他的个性。他只是个粗鲁、种族主义的人。所以，如果她一直把自己围在这样粗鲁、种族主义的人身边，最终，她会适应并采纳那种行为。我的意思是，我在心理学中学到了这一点，所以……
(LAUGHING) Sorry.
（笑）抱歉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I contacted Katie through her mom. I wanted them to know that Nevaeh and Katie's friendship would come up in this story. She told me they were not interested in talking and were moving past this incident.
我通过Katie的妈妈联系了她。我想让他们知道Nevaeh和Katie的友谊会出现在这个故事中。她告诉我他们没兴趣谈论，并且正在走出这次事件。
Nevaeh started to withdraw from Katie. When Katie confronted her about why she was ignoring her, the conversation Nevaeh had been avoiding happened.
Nevaeh开始疏远Katie。当Katie就为什么忽略她质问Nevaeh时，Nevaeh一直回避的谈话发生了。
And I was just like, hey, can you just straight-up be honest with me right now? Did you say something about me? Have you participated in this group chat? And then we got into a bit of an argument. She called me rude and low for ever suggesting a thing and that I was just, like, a bad friend for even thinking that.
我说，嘿，你能直接对我诚实吗？你说了关于我的坏话吗？你参与这个群聊了吗？然后我们就吵了一架。她称我粗鲁、卑鄙，因为我竟然建议这种事，说我简直是个坏朋友，竟然会那样想。
And then I was just like, OK, if you-- she told me that she wasn't involved in it. I don't know what to think about it. And so, I just was like, hey, OK, I'm going to distance myself from you. And that was it.
然后我只是说，好吧，如果你……她告诉我她没参与。我不知道该怎么想。所以，我只是说，嘿，好吧，我会疏远你。就这样。
Nevaeh hasn't talked to her since.
从那以后她就没再和她说过话了。
The Snapchat slave trade was almost nine months ago. Because there was a school investigation and a police investigation and a Title IX investigation, lots of adults-- school administrators, police-- know exactly what was said in those messages. But Nevaeh doesn't. It really bugs her.
Snapchat奴隶贸易已经是近九个月前的事了。因为有过学校调查、警察调查和第九修正案调查，许多成年人——学校行政人员、警察——确切地知道那些信息里说了什么。但Nevaeh不知道。这真的很困扰她。
How odd to have an otherwise ordinary rite of passage for any high schooler-- what did my friends say and do behind my back-- actually have a documented answer. Nevaeh says she asked for the full conversation from the school, but they never gave it to her and told her Katie shouldn't have shared it. They told her if she wanted to see more, she could file a Freedom of Information Act request, or a FOIA request. So she did. I did too.
对于任何高中生来说，有一个本来平凡的成人礼——我的朋友在我背后说了什么做了什么——竟然有一个有据可查的答案，这太奇怪了。Nevaeh说她向学校索要了完整的对话，但他们从未给她，并告诉她Katie不应该分享它。他们告诉她，如果想看更多，她可以提交《信息自由法》请求，即FOIA请求。所以她提交了。我也提交了。
And then, Nevaeh waited. I asked her, you know it could say some really hurtful stuff, right?
然后，Nevaeh等待着。我问她，你知道里面可能有一些非常伤人的话，对吧？
It may really hurt me. I think that if I see it, I can handle it. And I will handle it. And it'd just give me closure, not only for me, but closure, like, if Katie participated or not. Because I'm still questioning that. Was it the right decision to just cut Katie off? Or was I just paranoid, you know? What else was-- I mean, I-- you know? And so, just seeing if Katie participated or not, and then seeing what else was said about me, those two things will just give me, like, the most closure ever.
它可能真的会伤害我。我认为如果我看到它，我可以处理它。我会处理好的。这会给我一个了结，不仅是为了我，也是为了……如果Katie参与了或者没有参与。因为我仍然在质疑。就这样切断与Katie的联系是正确的决定吗？或者我只是多疑，你知道？还有什么……我的意思是，我……你知道？所以，只要看看Katie是否参与了，再看看还有什么关于我的说法，这两件事会给我带来前所未有的了结感。
My FOIA request came in first, a few weeks ago. It was close to 500 pages printed out, emails after emails, police reports, disciplinary hearing forms. But it's heavily redacted, which is honestly pretty normal for a FOIA. I brought it to Nevaeh's house, and she, her mom, and I sat at the kitchen table trying to sort through it all.
我的FOIA请求在几周前先有了回应。打印出来近500页，一封封的邮件、警察报告、纪律听证表格。但它被大量遮盖了，这对于FOIA请求来说通常是正常的。我把它带到Nevaeh家，她、她妈妈和我坐在厨房桌旁，试图理清所有内容。
There's so much information behind these black squares. I just-- wow, really? Cross out their names, but show me what they said.
这些黑色方块后面有太多的信息。我只是……哇，真的吗？划掉他们的名字，但告诉我他们说了什么。
The screenshots Nevaeh was hoping to see, fully blacked out. There were little bits of information here and there in the report, but it was hard to decipher. The was some new information in there. For one thing, the Snapchat wasn't the first time that a group of kids sold their Black peers in a slave auction.
Nevaeh希望能看到的截图，全部被涂黑了。报告里有零星的少量信息，但很难解读。里面有一些新的信息。首先，Snapchat并不是第一次有一群孩子在奴隶拍卖中出售他们的黑人同伴。
In the FOIA, the kid who started the slave trade in Traverse City said they saw it on TikTok. There was another one in Texas. Second, the FOIA made it clear that there were more screenshots than the ones Nevaeh had seen. All of them are blacked out.
在FOIA报告中，那个在特拉弗斯城发起奴隶贸易的孩子说他们是在TikTok上看到的。德克萨斯州也有过一次。其次，FOIA明确显示截图比Nevaeh看到的要多。所有这些都被涂黑了。
I could see the frustration and disappointment on Nevaeh's face as she flipped through page after page.
当Nevaeh翻阅一页又一页时，我能看到她脸上的沮丧和失望。
It's really frustrating to look at these just like tons of black pages and just boxes that are completely-- then again, I just want to know what they said. I don't understand why that's so difficult to just hand it over to me. I was in this group chat. I was a target. And so I feel like, as someone who was in the group chat and talked about in the group chat, I should be given the right to see what else was said about me because-- you know?
看这些成吨的黑色页面和完全被遮盖的方块真是太令人沮丧了……再说了，我只想知道他们说了什么。我不明白为什么这么难把它交给我。我在那个群聊里。我是目标。所以我觉得，作为一个在群聊里并被讨论的人，我有权看到还有什么关于我的说法，因为……你知道？
Nevaeh saw something in the FOIA that gave her pause. The names are blacked out, but she could see in the report that someone in the chat didn't participate. She kept seeing that over again, blacked out name, "did not participate." 50 pages later, blacked out name, "did not participate." Was that Katie?
Nevaeh在FOIA里看到了一些让她犹豫的东西。名字被涂黑了，但她能看到报告中有人没有参与。她反复看到这一点：被涂黑的名字，“没有参与”。50页后，被涂黑的名字，“没有参与”。那是Katie吗？
It just makes me question, like, maybe Katie was telling me the truth. And here I was just brushing it off because of how strongly I was focused on finding out if she was in it or not. So I guess, if anything, it just makes me question myself more and my judgments more.
这让我质疑，也许Katie是在对我讲真话。而我却因为我如此强烈地专注于找出她是否参与其中而忽视了这一点。所以我想，如果说有什么，它只是让我更怀疑自己和我的判断力。
The next day, Nevaeh sent me a text. She made the choice to believe that the blacked out name, the person who did not participate, was Katie. Reading the FOIA made Nevaeh think about their relationship, about who she could trust, something she'd been struggling with. Before this incident, she had no reason to think that Katie wasn't an honest person. She said she reached out to Katie to apologize and Katie had responded.
第二天，Nevaeh给我发了条短信。她选择了相信那个被涂黑的名字、那个没有参与的人是Katie。阅读FOIA让Nevaeh开始思考她们的关系，关于她可以信任谁，这曾是她一直挣扎的事情。在这次事件之前，她没有理由认为Katie不是一个诚实的人。她说她联系了Katie道歉，而Katie做出了回应。
Nevaeh did not just want to know what was said about her in the chat. She wanted everyone to know. She wanted to talk about it. But the message she felt like she kept getting from her school, the police, her friends, from the school board meeting in her town, from the 500-page blacked out FOIA, was we don't want to talk about this. We don't want to talk about racism.
Nevaeh不仅想知道群里关于她的说法。她想让所有人都知道。她想谈论它。但她感觉从学校、警察、朋友那里，从她所在城镇的校董会会议，从那份500页被涂黑的FOIA中传达的信息是：我们不想谈论这个。我们不想谈论种族主义。
It's the same message that has been on repeat everywhere in this moment of backlash. And as a kid, if that's the message you're getting, bury the racism, what do you do with that?
在这个反弹时刻，这是无处不在重复的信息。作为一个孩子，如果你得到的信息是“掩埋种族主义”，那你该怎么办？
About an hour after I left their house, Nevaeh's mom sent me a picture, Nevaeh in her room, sitting on her bed, surrounded by the FOIA, which she'd arranged in many little stacks of paper, like a detective sorting and sifting through the clues, still puzzling, still trying to find something to help her make sense of it all.
我离开她家大约一小时后，Nevaeh的妈妈发给我一张照片，Nevaeh在房间里，坐在床上，被FOIA文件包围着，她把这些文件整理成许多小堆，像侦探在搜集证据，依然感到困惑，依然试图找到能让她理解这一切的东西。
Coming up, a person who does not want to know anything about what's being said behind their back. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一个不想知道背后被议论什么的人。过一分钟，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Emanuele Berry in for Ira Glass. Today's show, "Talking While Black," stories of people caught up in this moment of backlash. We've gone from 2020, companies tweeting out Black Lives Matter, there's all these diversity initiatives, to now, where it feels like even just saying something is Black is controversial. States are passing laws to limit conversations about racism. Black people are losing their jobs for talking about race too much.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Emanuele Berry，代班Ira Glass。今天的节目，“黑人谈话”，讲述了在这个反弹时刻被卷入的人们的故事。我们已经从2020年企业发布推文支持“黑人的命也是命”、充满多元化倡议的时期，到了现在——感觉连说“某些事物是黑人的”都成了争议。各州正在立法限制关于种族主义的谈论。黑人因为谈论种族太多而失去了工作。
I keep returning to this question over the last few months. In this backlash, what are you allowed to say? Like, as a Black person, what about Black lives or the Black experience is actually OK to talk about? This next story gets at this question.
过去几个月里，我不断回到这个问题。在这种反弹中，你被允许谈论什么？作为一名黑人，关于黑人生活或黑人经历，究竟什么是可以谈论的？下一个故事触及了这个问题。
We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, The Farce Awakens. One place where you can see this dizzying whiplash is books by Black people and about Black people. After the murder of George Floyd, sales of Black books skyrocketed. Ibram X. Kendi's Stamped from the Beginning, The New Jim Crow, So You Want to Talk About Race, were all of a sudden bestsellers.
我们进入节目的第二幕，“闹剧觉醒”。你可以看到这种令人眩晕的反弹的一个领域是黑人撰写以及关于黑人的书籍。乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后，黑人书籍的销量飙升。Ibram X. Kendi的《从一开始就打上烙印》、《新种族隔离》、《所以你想谈论种族》，一时间都成了畅销书。
For a window of time, people really wanted to hear what Black authors had to say. And then, they dramatically did not want to hear anymore. Not only did sales slow, but there are now efforts to ban many of these books that were so celebrated a little over a year ago.
有一段时间，人们真心想听到黑人作者要说些什么。然后，他们突然不想再听了。不仅销量放缓，而且现在还有努力要禁掉许多在一年前还备受推崇的书籍。
Producer Chana Joffe-Walt spoke with one author who found his book banned and whose professional arc is sort of a mirror for this backlash. Here's Chana.
制作人Chana Joffe-Walt采访了一位发现自己的书被禁，且其职业轨迹也某种程度上是这次反弹写照的作者。这是Chana。
I learned about this particular banned book from Deborah Caldwell-Stone. She's the director of the American Library Association's Office for Intellectual Freedom. Her job is to track efforts to censor and ban books.
我是从Deborah Caldwell-Stone那里了解到这本特定的被禁书籍的。她是美国图书馆协会知识自由办公室的主任。她的工作是追踪审查和禁书的努力。
And she was telling me she's never seen anything like this fall before, in her decades on the job, just the number of books being challenged, removed from school library shelves. Many books about LGBTQ people, she says those have been contested for years, but more recently, Toni Morrison, Dr. Ibram X. Kendi, The Hate U Give, a novel about the aftermath of police brutality.
她告诉我，在她几十年的工作中，她从未见过像今年秋天这样——挑战、从学校图书馆下架书籍的数量之多。许多关于LGBTQ人群的书籍，她说那些书多年来一直受到争议，但最近，Toni Morrison、Ibram X. Kendi博士、《仇恨的代价》（一部关于警察暴力后果的小说）也被盯上了。
And in Texas there was a mother who halted an author presentation by Jerry Craft by claiming falsely that New Kid represented critical race theory.
在德克萨斯州，有一位母亲通过虚假声称《新来的孩子》（New Kid）代表了批判性种族理论，从而叫停了Jerry Craft的作者讲座。
New Kid, the, like, comic book, the graphic novel?
《新来的孩子》，那本漫画书，那本图画小说？
Yes, New Kid.
是的，《新来的孩子》。
New Kid is a book my children read. It's about a 12-year-old Black boy who goes to a new school.
《新来的孩子》是我孩子读的书。它是关于一个12岁的黑人男孩去了一所新学校的故事。
Jerry was scheduled to give an author presentation to the kids in Katy, Texas. And they lined up this big event. All the kids were anticipating meeting Jerry via Zoom. And one mother stopped the whole thing by claiming that it was critical race theory.
Jerry原定要在德克萨斯州凯蒂市为孩子们举办作者讲座。他们排满了这个盛大的活动。所有的孩子都在期待通过Zoom见到Jerry。而一位母亲声称它是批判性种族理论，从而阻止了整个活动。
Wow.
哇。
Jerry Craft has been invited to speak to thousands of schools over the years to do author presentations like the one in Katy, Texas, because New Kid was widely acclaimed. It won a ton of awards. It was a number one New York Times bestseller, translated into a dozen languages. New Kid is a semi-autobiographical graphic novel about a boy, Jordan, who wants to be an artist and go to art school. But his parents put him in a fancy private school.
多年来，Jerry Craft受邀到成千上万所学校进行作者讲座，就像在德克萨斯州凯蒂市的那次一样，因为《新来的孩子》广受好评。它赢得了大量奖项。它是《纽约时报》排名第一的畅销书，被翻译成十几种语言。《新来的孩子》是一部半自传性质的图画小说，讲述了一个男孩Jordan的故事，他想成为一名艺术家，进入艺术学校。但他的父母把他送进了一所高档的私立学校。
Jordan is one of only a few Black kids. A lot of the kids are wealthy. The campus is vast. And you watch Jordan, this funny, earnest kid, navigate a new environment. There's culture shock. There's new friendships. It's part fish-out-of-water story and part just kid in middle school figuring out crushes in the cafeteria and things like should he do sports or the musical.
Jordan是仅有的几名黑人学生之一。许多孩子很富有。校园非常广阔。你看着Jordan，这个有趣、真诚的孩子，在这个新环境中导航。这里有文化冲击。有新的友谊。它既是“局外人”的故事，也是关于在中学食堂里经历暗恋，以及诸如他应该参加体育运动还是音乐剧之类事情的孩子的故事。
Jerry Craft told me when he put new kid out there, the response was amazing. Everything, it was all like a great big hug from the world. People wrote him to say, my kid wants to be an artist now. My kid loved your book. Or--
Jerry Craft告诉我，当他推出《新来的孩子》时，反响非常惊人。一切，就像来自世界的一个大大的拥抱。人们写信告诉他，我的孩子现在想成为一名艺术家了。我的孩子喜欢你的书。或者——
Hey, you know, my kid has never been a reader before and he read your book three times. Like, that's what I'm used to.
嘿，你知道，我的孩子以前从不读书，他读了你的书三遍。是的，这是我习惯的。
Mm-hmm. Love--
嗯哼。爱——
Right!
对！
You're used to love and admiration.
你习惯了爱和钦佩。
Right. So now it's like, hey, can you comment here in the BBC? I'm like, no. Like, what is this?
对。所以现在就像是，嘿，你能评论一下BBC的这个吗？我说，不。比如，这是什么？
This is not his thing, controversy. Jerry was a kid who loved to draw, who became an adult who kept drawing. He spends most of his time in a room by himself making pictures. When he published New Kid in 2019, Jerry had been writing comics for decades. This was the book he'd always wanted to write, the book he wished he'd had as a kid, with a Black character who seemed just regular. Jerry says he remembers going to the library as a kid and it was always the general books and the Black books.
这不是他擅长的领域，争议。Jerry是个热爱画画的孩子，后来成长为一个一直画画的成年人。他大部分时间都一个人待在房间里画画。2019年出版《新来的孩子》时，Jerry已经写了数十年的漫画了。这是他一直想写的书，他希望自己在孩子时能读到的那种书，书中的黑人角色看起来很普通。Jerry说他记得自己小时候去图书馆，总是只有一般书籍和黑人书籍。
The general books are "wants to live better." And our books are "just wants to live." You know, your books, "His father is king." Our books, "His father is gone." Lives in a magical kingdom, lives in the hood. All the books with Black protagonists were history or misery.
一般书籍是“想活得更好”。而我们的书是“只是想活着”。你知道，你的书是“他父亲是国王”。我们的书是“他父亲走了”。生活在魔法王国，生活在街区。所有带有黑人主角的书都是关于历史或苦难的。
No kid like me ever made it to the end of a book. There was no dad. There was nothing-- the kids always lived on the south side of somewhere that was just really horrible. And it was gangs or slavery or civil rights or police brutality. And I'm like, can I just see a kid who the biggest problem of the day is whether he wants to play Xbox or PlayStation? And that's why I do what I do. I make those books that I wish I had.
没有像我这样的孩子能读完一本书。没有爸爸。什么都没有——孩子们总是生活在某个真的很糟糕的地方的南区。要么是帮派，要么是奴隶制，要么是民权或警察暴力。我说，我能只看到一个最大的麻烦就是决定是想玩Xbox还是PlayStation的孩子吗？这就是我做这件事的原因。我创作那些我希望自己曾拥有的书。
That's the thing about New Kid being banned. So many of the other Black authors with banned books are writing explicitly about racism or history, books about how slavery has shaped America, police brutality, how to be an anti-racist. But New Kid, this is not a history book. It's not about police violence or slavery or civil rights. It's a story about finding your place in middle school.
这就是《新来的孩子》被禁的事情。许多其他被禁书籍的黑人作者是在明确地写关于种族主义或历史、关于奴隶制如何塑造了美国、警察暴力、如何成为一名反种族主义者的书。但《新来的孩子》，这不是一本历史书。它不是关于警察暴力、奴隶制或民权的。它是关于在中学找到自己位置的故事。
There are racial slights in a sort of daily way. White classmates and teachers make assumptions about where Jordan's from, that he's a great athlete. They say ignorant things, try to touch a Black friend's hair. Administrators continue to call a long-standing Black teacher "Coach," even though he's never coached anything. Jordan often finds this stuff funny. He laughs about it with another Black classmate.
书中有一些日常式的微歧视。白人同学和老师对Jordan来自哪里做出了假设，假设他是个伟大的运动员。他们说无知的话，试着触摸他黑人朋友的头发。行政人员继续称一名资深的黑人教师为“教练”，尽管他从没教过任何运动。Jordan通常觉得这些东西很有趣。他和另一个黑人同学一起笑话这些。
Sometimes he finds it confusing or annoying, but it's not tragic. These are just things that happen on the way, alongside lots of other experiences with his white classmates and teachers, including good experiences. Honestly, the most dramatic thing that happens in this story is that Jordan loses his sketchbook. What is there to object to?
有时他觉得这令人困惑或恼火，但这并不悲惨。这些只是发生在他人生旅途中的事情，与他白人同学和老师的其他许多经历并存，包括好的经历。老实说，这个故事中最具戏剧性的事情是Jordan弄丢了他的素描本。有什么可反对的？
When I talked to Jerry, I didn't know the specifics of the objections in Texas. And I kind of expected Jerry to fill me in, but he knew even less than me. He read enough of one article to understand that a white parent had complained about his book, was calling it critical race theory, a term Jerry had to then Google. And he closed the article without finishing it. He had work to do.
我和Jerry交谈时，不知道德克萨斯州反对意见的具体细节。我本以为Jerry会告诉我，但他知道的甚至比我还少。他读了一篇报道的部分内容，理解到是一位白人家长投诉了他的书，称其为批判性种族理论——Jerry后来不得不去谷歌搜索这个词。他没有读完就关掉了报道。他还有工作要做。
But friends and strangers kept messaging him. How crazy, your book, banned.
但朋友和陌生人不断给他发信息。太疯狂了，你的书被禁了。
So one person sent me the actual school board link. I guess they filmed the school board? And I just refused to watch that because when I'm sitting for 16 hours a day drawing humorous stuff for kids, I have to protect my own brain and my own psyche because I don't want my next book, kids to be like, wow, Mr. Craft used to be funny. Now he's so depressing. So I have to be in a really good mental space for that.
所以有人发给我校董会的实际链接。我猜他们拍摄了校董会？我拒绝看那个，因为当我每天坐16个小时为孩子们画有趣的东西时，我必须保护我自己的大脑和心灵，因为我不希望我的下一本书，让孩子们觉得，哇，Craft先生以前很风趣。现在他好压抑。所以我必须保持一个非常好的心理状态。
So, you knew. I mean, it sounds like you knew that that was something that you weren't going to want to watch.
所以，你知道了。我的意思是，听起来你知道那是不想看的东西。
Yeah. I did not want to go down that rabbit hole.
是的。我不想掉进那个兔子洞。
What did you imagine was down that rabbit hole that was scary to you?
你想象那个兔子洞下面有什么让你害怕的东西？
The complaint that I saw was that I'm teaching kids critical race theory. So the college course that mentions things such as institutional racism and all these really heavy, deep things that they are studying and picking apart in college, I was now breaking that down for fourth and fifth graders apparently. So--
我看到的投诉是我在教孩子们批判性种族理论。所以，那个提及诸如制度性种族主义等所有这些非常沉重、深刻的事物，在大学里进行学习和剖析的课程，现在显然被我分解给四年级和五年级的孩子了。所以——
[RING]
[铃声]
Ooh, sorry. That's not supposed to happen.
噢，抱歉。那不应该发生。
Oh, is that for me? Is that Katy, Texas?
噢，那是给我的吗？那是德克萨斯州凯蒂市的吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, we wanted equal opportunity.
就像，我们想要平等的机会。
Yeah, they wanted to know what you're talking about.
是的，他们想知道你在说什么。
We have to give an opposing viewpoint.
我们必须提供相反的观点。
That's how I do my interviews. I just, like, in the middle, I get a call from the opposing side, and then the two of you duke it out.
这就是我做采访的方式。我就像，中间，我接到对立方的电话，然后你们两个决斗一下。
Right, there you go.
对，这就是了。
I did not stage a call with the mom who complained about Jerry Craft's books, but I did talk to her. And I watched her testimony at the Katy school board meetings, the ones Jerry Kraft would not watch. Her name is Bonnie Anderson. She has three kids in the schools. She's very involved in local school politics. She's part of a lawsuit against the school district's mask mandate. And she ran for school board last spring but lost.
我没有安排和那位投诉Jerry Craft书籍的母亲通电话，但我确实和她谈了。我看了她在凯蒂校董会会议上的证词，那些Jerry Kraft不愿看的会议。她的名字是Bonnie Anderson。她有三个孩子在这些学校上学。她非常参与当地学校的政治。她是反对学区口罩强制令诉讼的一部分。去年春天她还竞选了校董会，但输了。
Bonnie told me she first encountered Jerry's book when she got a flyer in her kid's backpack announcing the author visit. So she got the books, New Kid, and the follow-up book, Class Act, and read them both herself.
Bonnie告诉我，她第一次接触到Jerry的书是在她孩子的书包里收到一张传单，宣布作者访问活动。所以她拿到了《新来的孩子》和后续的书《班级行动》，并亲自读了这两本。
I don't know if you've-- have you read these books?
我不知道你是否——你读过这些书吗？
Yeah, my kids read them.
是的，我的孩子们读过。
OK, OK. [CHUCKLE] I don't even know where to start. So the first thing that I noticed is all of the microaggressions that the author is depicting.
好的，好的。[轻笑] 我甚至不知道从哪儿开始。所以我注意到的第一件事是作者描绘的所有微歧视。
Microaggressions, meaning the everyday thoughtless stuff white people in the book say around Black kids. Bonnie worried how reading those depictions might make white kids feel. The district told me there was another parent too, who apparently filed a complaint that New Kid includes vulgarity. But they would not provide that person's name.
微歧视，意思是书中白人孩子周围的白人所说的日常不经意的话。Bonnie担心阅读这些描绘会让白人孩子有什么感觉。学区告诉我还有另一位家长，显然也提交了一份投诉，称《新来的孩子》包含粗俗内容。但他们没有提供那个人的名字。
Bonnie, though, was very public. She cared enough about this to create a petition demanding the district cancel Jerry Craft's event. It got 400 signatures. To Bonnie, the book has a clear agenda. Jerry set out to convince people systemic racism is real and show how privileged and awful white people are.
不过，Bonnie非常公开。她关心这件事，以至于发起了一份请愿书，要求学区取消Jerry Craft的活动。它获得了400个签名。对Bonnie来说，这本书有一个明确的议程。Jerry着手说服人们系统性种族主义是真实的，并展示白人是多么享有特权和糟糕。
He's dressing it up with funny or dramatic moments that, to her, seem totally over the top, like the scene where the dad gets pulled over by the cops and is super nervous. She says, you really think that happens? Or the white mom who worries her kid's Black friend might take offense if she serves watermelon for a snack. Come on, she says.
他用有趣或戏剧性的时刻包装它，在她看来，那些时刻完全是过火的，比如爸爸被警察拦下，非常紧张的那一幕。她说，你真的认为那种事会发生吗？或者那个担心孩子黑人朋友如果吃西瓜作为零食会觉得被冒犯的白人妈妈。得了吧，她说。
A lot of our conversation was Bonnie questioning parts of the book, and me saying, I think that's based on Jerry's own life.
我们谈话的很大一部分是Bonnie质疑书的部分，而我则说，我认为那基于Jerry自己的生活。
You really think that Jerry Craft went to an all-Jewish school, which he did, and you really think he was given KFC gift certificates? Because he says these are things he went through.
你真的认为Jerry Craft去了一所全犹太学校（他确实去了），而且你真的认为他被赠予了KFC礼券吗？因为他说这些是他经历过的事情。
Wait, it's not a Jewish school.
等等，这不是犹太学校。
He did. He went to a mostly Jewish school.
他去了。他去了一所主要是犹太人的学校。
He went to Fieldston, which is not a Jewish school.
他去了Fieldston，那不是一所犹太学校。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
But you're saying you don't believe that that actually happened to him.
但你在说你不相信那真的发生在他身上。
Regardless, let's just pretend that all the things he wrote about, being called an Oreo, all those things actually happened. Regardless, let's just pretend for a second that all those things happened. Or let's take his word, all those things happened. It doesn't matter.
无论如何，让我们假装他写的所有事情，被叫成Oreo，所有那些事情真的发生了。无论如何，让我们假装一会儿所有那些事情都发生了。或者让我们相信他的话，所有那些事情都发生了。这不重要。
Wait? Why doesn't that matter?
等等？为什么那不重要？
Because you don't harm future generations of children because you went through a bad experience. You don't poison the minds of my children even if it happened. You do not poison the minds of other kids and make them feel like they have to make concessions for being white.
因为你不能因为你自己经历过糟糕的经历而去伤害下一代孩子。你不能毒害我孩子的思想，即使它真的发生了。你不应该毒害其他孩子的思想，让他们觉得因为是白人就必须做出让步。
This is an idea that is repeated in a lot of the efforts to ban books. The idea that these books will psychologically harm children, usually white children.
这是一个在许多禁书努力中反复出现的想法。认为这些书籍会在心理上伤害孩子，通常是白人孩子。
When you say it poisons the minds of your kids, what's the thing that you're worried is going to happen to your kids reading these books?
当你谈到毒害你孩子的思想时，你担心这些书会对你的孩子造成什么影响？
So these books teach children the preordained conclusion that white children have wealth, status, and race privilege, while children of color must suffer the racist ignorance of these privileged families. You remember from the books that the white mom does nothing but play yoga all day and the white boy feels neglected. And they live in a mansion and they drive in the Range Rover.
所以这些书教给孩子们一个预定的结论，即白人孩子拥有财富、地位和种族特权，而有色人种孩子必须承受这些特权家庭的种族主义无知。你从书中记得那个白人妈妈除了每天做瑜伽什么都不做，白人男孩感到被忽视。他们住在豪宅里，开着路虎。
It's a Mercedes, but sure. For Bonnie, these characterizations would be damaging to her kids if they read the books, which they haven't. New Kid is a book that is entirely focused on the perspective of a Black boy, the things he sees and experiences.
是奔驰，但随你吧。对Bonnie来说，如果她的孩子阅读这些书籍（他们还没读过），这些刻画将是有害的。《新来的孩子》是一本完全集中在黑人男孩视角、他所见所闻的书。
There are white characters. Some of them are mean. Some of them are Jordan's best friends. One of them talks to everyone through sock puppets. But they're peripheral. The story is about Jordan. So I would assume, like with any well-told story, kids reading this book would identify with the main character, since he's the protagonist of the story.
书中有白人角色。其中一些很刻薄。其中一些是Jordan最好的朋友。其中一个用袜偶和大家交谈。但他们是边缘化的。故事是关于Jordan的。所以我会假设，像任何讲述得好的故事一样，阅读这本书的孩子会认同主角，因为他是故事的主人公。
I want to say something here I feel obliged to say, but also feels a little embarrassing for all of us that I have to say it at all. This book, Jerry Craft's book, New Kid, is not critical race theory. Jerry Craft did not create a fictional 12-year-old Black boy, Jordan Banks, to promote a complex legal theory about systemic racism. And although it is a work of fiction, most of what Bonnie objects to in these books did actually happen.
我想在这里说一些我觉得有义务说的话，但也觉得我们不得不说这些话真的很尴尬。这本书，Jerry Craft的书《新来的孩子》，不是批判性种族理论。Jerry Craft并没有创造一个虚构的12岁黑人男孩Jordan Banks来推广关于系统性种族主义的复杂法律理论。尽管它是一部虚构作品，但Bonnie反对的书中大部分内容确实发生了。
How much of this is just your direct life experience?
其中有多少是你的直接生活经历？
There's a lot of it. I was the light-skinned African-American kid, born in Harlem, grew up in Washington Heights. The house where Jordan Banks lives is a brownstone. That is literally the house where I was born and spent the first 25 years of my life. My mom and dad did not want me to go to art school.
有很多。我是肤色较浅的非裔美国孩子，出生在哈林区，在华盛顿高地长大。Jordan Banks住的房子是褐砂石。那字面上就是我出生并度过前25年人生的地方。我爸妈不想让我去艺术学校。
But you, like Jordan Banks, wanted to go to art school?
但你，像Jordan Banks一样，想去艺术学校？
I wanted to go to art school. So they sent me to a school in Riverdale. And here, they send Jordan Banks to a school called Riverdale Academy Day School, or RAD, for short.
我想去艺术学校。所以他们把我送到了Riverdale的一所学校。在这里，他们把Jordan Banks送进了一所叫Riverdale Academy Day School（简称RAD）的学校。
Jordan Banks felt out of place. Jerry Craft felt out of place. Jordan Banks' classmates all inexplicably wore pink but called it salmon. Same with Jerry Craft.
Jordan Banks感觉格格不入。Jerry Craft感觉格格不入。Jordan Banks的同学们莫明其妙地都穿粉色，但称其为鲑鱼色。Jerry Craft也是。
The whole Vineyard Vines thing, that was like the unofficial uniform. So I changed it, in New Kid, to Grapevine Groves. It's like, wow, you kids sure wear a lot of pink here. It's like, no, it's not pink. It's salmon.
那个Vineyard Vines风，那是非官方制服。所以我在《新来的孩子》中把它改成了Grapevine Groves。就像，哇，你们这些孩子在这里穿这么多粉色。就像，不，不是粉色。是鲑鱼色。
And all the things Jordan Banks observes or experiences, a white mom who worries about serving watermelon, a nerve-wracking interaction with a cop, white classmates touching your hair, assuming you like basketball, they happened to Jerry or Jerry's kids.
以及Jordan Banks观察或经历的所有事情——担心供应西瓜的白人妈妈、与警察紧张的互动、白人同学触摸你的头发、假设你喜欢篮球——它们都发生在了Jerry或Jerry的孩子身上。
Being called the wrong name. You know, hey, Deandre. I'm not Deandre. I'm Drew.
被叫错名字。你知道，嘿，Deandre。我不是Deandre。我是Drew。
Like that's the other one?
那也是其中一个？
Uh-huh. Right, that's the other one.
嗯哼。对，那是另一个。
That's what's so interesting to me about this book in particular being kind of drawn into this CRT battle that's supposedly about history. But your book is not a history book. This is literally just you writing down the story of your life.
这就是为什么我发现这本书特别被拉进这场理应是关于历史的CRT之战中非常有趣的原因。但你的书不是历史书。这字面上只是你写下的你生活的故事。
Right, yeah. It literally is based on what I actually see. There's nothing that I haven't lived myself.
对，是的。它确实基于我实际看到的东西。没有什么是我自己没经历过的。
With one exception, those KFC gift certificates? Jerry says he made that up. One other thing Jerry pointed out that really happened to him, the last chapter of New Kid, it's called "The Farce Awakens." It's when Jordan loses his sketchbook, the one he carries everywhere. He's super stressed because it has all his thoughts and drawings from that year. It's sort of like a visual diary.
除了一点例外，那些KFC礼券？Jerry说那是他编的。Jerry指出的另一件真正发生在他身上的事情，是《新来的孩子》最后一章，它叫“闹剧觉醒”。那是Jordan弄丢了他的素描本的时候，他随身携带的那本。他压力很大，因为里面有他那一年所有的想法和画作。它有点像视觉日记。
It turns out his teacher, Ms. Rawle, is holding his sketchbook when he comes into the classroom. She's read it.
事实证明，他的老师Ms. Rawle在他走进教室时拿着他的素描本。她读了它。
And she reads it, and she's like, Jordan, why are you so angry? It's like, I'm not angry.
她读了它，说：Jordan，你为什么这么生气？就像，我不生气。
And the teacher's upset about what's in the notebook.
而老师对笔记本里的东西感到不安。
Right, because he will complain about being called the wrong name or just different things like that, or people touching his friend's hair. And so, she's like, Jordan, you're special. You're here.
对，因为他会抱怨被叫错名字，或者诸如此类的不同事情，或者人们触摸他朋友的头发。所以，她就像，Jordan，你是特别的。你在这里。
And he's like, yeah, but Ms. Rawle, would you take a job at a school in my neighborhood so you can be special? And she kind of gets on him. He's like, so, let me get this right. It's OK for this stuff to happen to me. It's just not OK for me to talk about it. And that sums up this whole thing that's going on now.
他就像，是的，但Ms. Rawle，你会去我附近的一所学校工作吗，这样你也能变得特别？她有点对他发火。他就像，所以，让我弄清楚这一点。这事发生在我身上是可以的。只是我不可以说出来就不行。这总结了现在正在发生的整件事。
Oh.
噢。
Right? There are things based on my life and based on my kids' lives.
对吧？这些东西基于我的生活和孩子们的生活。
Does it feel like a grown-up version of what happens to Jerry Banks in your novel?
这感觉像是发生在你小说里Jerry Banks身上事情的成年版吗？
I love how you said Jerry Banks because that is right.
我喜欢你说Jerry Banks的方式，因为那是对的。
Jordan, Jordan Banks.
Jordan，Jordan Banks。
No, you're right. It is Jerry Banks. We are one and the same. No, it's exactly the same.
不，你是对的。它是Jerry Banks。我们是一个人。不，完全一样。
Yeah.
是的。
Ms. Rawle found Jordan's sketchbook and said that it's a polemic and that it's angry. And this woman found my book and says it's a polemic and it's angry, and, yeah.
Ms. Rawle发现了Jordan的素描本，说那是煽动性的，说他很愤怒。而这个女人发现了我的书，说它是煽动性的，说它很愤怒，是的。
I went back to that last chapter recently. And what stood out reading it this time, knowing it had been banned, is that even 12-year-old Jordan Banks knows that his account of his own life will not be acceptable to his white teacher and is better kept in the safety of his journal. He knows his teacher won't be able to read it without feeling personally attacked. He knows that what has happened to him will not matter as much as how it makes her feel to read about it. He already knows that even if it's all real, she'd rather he keep it to himself.
我最近回到了最后一章。这次读的时候，知道它被禁了，我感到特别突出的是，即使是12岁的Jordan Banks也知道，他对自己生活的叙述对他白人老师来说是不可接受的，最好保存在日记的安全中。他知道，如果不感到受到人身攻击，他的老师是无法读到它的。他知道，比起读到它会让她有什么感觉，发生在他身上的事情并不重要。他已经知道，即使这一切都是真实的，她也宁愿他保密。
Eight states have recently passed legislation restricting the teaching of racism and bias in public schools. Texas is one of them. Nearly 20 more states have introduced or plan to introduce similar legislation. These laws almost never list specific books you can't teach. They talk about feelings. They prohibit teaching any lessons that might make students feel, quote, "discomfort, guilt, or anguish" because of their race.
八个州最近通过了立法，限制在公立学校教授种族主义和偏见。德克萨斯州是其中之一。近20个州已经引入或计划引入类似的立法。这些法律几乎从不列出你不能教授的具体书籍。他们谈论感受。他们禁止教授任何可能让学生因为种族而感到——引用——“不适、内疚或痛苦”的课程。
After Bonnie's petition and the complaint about New Kid including vulgarity, the district responded, launched an investigation, and said it was using the new Texas law to evaluate the book. It also pulled Jerry's books from the library and called off his author visit.
在Bonnie的请愿和关于《新来的孩子》包含粗俗内容的投诉后，学区做出了回应，发起了调查，并表示正在使用新的德克萨斯州法律来评估这本书。它还将Jerry的书从图书馆下架，并取消了他的作者访问活动。
In Pennsylvania, a group of parents got the school board to ban a list of diverse books, including a children's book about Rosa Parks. They worried the books could be used to make white children feel guilty. A group of white moms in Tennessee have demanded a book about Martin Luther King, Jr. and the March on Washington be removed from the curriculum. They also objected to a chapter book called The Story of Ruby Bridges because it makes it seem like white people are bad.
在宾夕法尼亚州，一群家长让校董会禁掉了一系列多元化的书籍，包括一本关于罗莎·帕克斯的童书。他们担心这些书会被用来让白人孩子感到内疚。田纳西州的一群白人妈妈要求从课程中删除一本关于马丁·路德·金和华盛顿游行的书。她们还反对一本叫《鲁比·布里奇斯的故事》的书，因为那让白人看起来很坏。
These are parents who claim reading books about Black experiences or Black history or just a Black kid going to middle school will harm their children. And their desire to protect their kids from discomfort is now enshrined in the law.
这些家长的声称是，阅读关于黑人经历或黑人历史，或者只是黑人孩子上中学的书会伤害他们的孩子。他们保护孩子免受不适的愿望现在已被写入法律。
The investigation into New Kid lasted 10 days, at which point, the district announced their findings, no inappropriate material. Children would be allowed to read this book in Katy, Texas. And Jerry's event with the kids was rescheduled. It went fine. Kids asked the same questions they always do. What inspired you? Is there going to be a movie?
对《新来的孩子》的调查持续了10天，届时学区公布了他们的调查结果：没有不当内容。孩子们将被允许在德克萨斯州凯蒂市阅读这本书。Jerry与孩子们的活动也被重新安排了。进行得很顺利。孩子们问着他们总是问的问题。什么激励了你？会有电影吗？
But that same day, the Katy school board had a meeting. Parents showed up to complain that the event was allowed to go forward, that critical race theory was infiltrating the schools. And they demanded a full audit of the whole library, which, just recently, they won. There was one mom who got up to defend New Kid and to say what the book means to her family.
但在同一天，凯蒂校董会召开了一次会议。家长们出席投诉该活动被允许进行，批判性种族理论正在渗透到学校中。他们要求对整个图书馆进行全面审计，就在最近，他们赢了。有一位妈妈站起来为《新来的孩子》辩护，并讲述了这本书对她家庭的意义。
I've never spoken before, so this is about the Jerry Craft book. I'm sure you all know about that.
我以前从未发言过，所以这是关于Jerry Craft的书。我相信你们都知道。
Her name is Courtney. She's a Black woman standing before a line of board members who all appear to be white. Here's what she had to say.
她的名字是Courtney。她是一位黑人女性，站在一排看起来都是白人的董事会成员面前。这是她要说的话。
Even though the books will be placed on shelves again, I am concerned to what led to them being removed. Can you count on your hand and tell me how many people of color you've ever had at your home? If you're having trouble or just can't remember a day or time, please tell me, what do you possibly know about what's wrong with a book you've never lived?
尽管这些书将再次摆上书架，但我担心的是导致它们被下架的原因。你们能数一数并告诉我你们家里有多少有色人种吗？如果你们数不出来或者想不起某天或某个时间，请告诉我，你们对一本自己从未经历过的书有什么意见？
Have you ever went to work for two years and have someone call you Britney every morning? I have because my name is Courtney. You know the correlation if you've read the book, New Kid, by Jerry Craft. Did you read it?
你们有没有去工作两年，每天早上有人叫你Britney？我有，因为我的名字是Courtney。如果你读过Jerry Craft的《新来的孩子》，你就会知道关联。你读过吗？
Have you ever served this great country in the Washington, DC, inauguration of 2000, Korea, 2001, Iraq, 2003, Afghanistan, 2015, Fort Hood, 2016, only to have your 15-year-old twin son call you in the middle of a workday saying he doesn't like his Paytoh high school, and learned that the doctor visits of anxiety and stomach pains for the last 12 months were only due to a white teen calling your son the N-word for the last year of 2018? Well, I have. If you read the book, you'd understand the correlation, once again, of the Oreo joke.
你有没有为这个伟大的国家服务过，2000年华盛顿特区的就职典礼，韩国2001，伊拉克2003，阿富汗2015，胡德堡2016，结果却在工作日中间接到15岁双胞胎儿子的电话，说他不喜欢他的Paytoh高中，了解到过去12个月的焦虑和胃痛看病，仅仅是因为一个白人少年在2018年的最后一年一直用N字头词汇称呼你的儿子？好吧，我有。如果你读过这本书，你会再次理解Oreo笑话的关联。
How dare you, 444 signatures, remove what little representation my culture has to show its reality and literature form on the modern day shelves. I don't applaud you for placing the books back on the shelves. My only hope is that you not allow the unknown and false narratives to sway your judgment on needed representation of us all. Representation does matter.
你们怎么敢，444个签名，移除我的文化在现代书架上文学形式中仅存的代表性。我不会为你们把书放回书架鼓掌。我唯一的希望是你们不要让未知和错误的叙述左右你们对我们所有人需要的代表性的判断。代表性确实很重要。
Please don't thank me for my service. I do it because I love it. Many friends and battles have died and bled for it. As for Katy ISD, do what you should and need to do to uphold the standards of fairness, justice, and representation for this school district so I can thank you for yours. Thank you.
请不要感谢我的服务。我做是因为我热爱。许多朋友和战友为此而死，为此而流血。至于Katy ISD，做你们应该做和需要做的事，维护本学区公平、正义和代表性的标准，这样我才能感谢你们。谢谢。
Thank you. The next speaker is Emily Lewis.
谢谢。下一位发言者是Emily Lewis。
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
[零星的掌声]
Mr. President, you seem to have a problem with our country.
主席先生，你似乎对我们的国家有问题。
In so many corners of the country right now, parents, usually white parents, are showing up to meetings just like this to express their fear, to say they don't want their children harmed or feeling uncomfortable. Courtney is talking about harm that is already happening.
目前在全国的许多角落，家长们，通常是白人家长，正出现在像这样的会议上表达他们的恐惧，说他们不希望他们的孩子受到伤害或感到不适。Courtney谈论的是已经在发生的伤害。
And Jerry Craft is already uncomfortable. He wrote a whole book about feeling uncomfortable. He told me you just learn to deal with it. He never had any laws protecting him from discomfort or school boards worried about his discomfort. What he had was the ability to write it down, to talk about it.
而Jerry Craft已经感到不适了。他写了一整本书关于感到不适的内容。他告诉我你只是学会去处理它。他从未有任何法律保护他免受不适，也没有校董会担心他的不适。他拥有的是把它写下来、谈论它的能力。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show.
Chana Joffe-Walt是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and me, Emanuele Berry, and edited by Chana Jaffe-Walt. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Damian Graef, Seth Lind, Mary Marge Locker, Tobin Low, Lina Misitzis, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alix Spiegel, Laura Starcheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, Chloee Weiner, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目由Robyn Semien和我，Emanuele Berry制作，由Chana Jaffe-Walt编辑。参与今天节目制作的人员包括Bim Adewunmi、Susan Burton、Ben Calhoun、Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Andrea López Cruzado、Damian Graef、Seth Lind、Mary Marge Locker、Tobin Low、Lina Misitzis、Michelle Navarro、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Alix Spiegel、Laura Starcheski、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney、Julie Whitaker、Chloee Weiner和Diane Wu。我们的总编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman，高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to New Leonard Media of Traverse City, Mark L. Wilson, Nikole Hannah Jones, Orlando Dial, Eve Ewing, Rob Kerr, Sophia Hassen, Seven Forsen, Andrea-Grace Makuna, Damilola Awofisayo, Jewell Coulter, Ami Chum, Michele Togbe, and Gianna Maltbie.
今天特别感谢特拉弗斯城的New Leonard Media、Mark L. Wilson、Nikole Hannah Jones、Orlando Dial、Eve Ewing、Rob Kerr、Sophia Hassen、Seven Forsen、Andrea-Grace Makuna、Damilola Awofisayo、Jewell Coulter、Ami Chum、Michele Togbe和Gianna Maltbie。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes absolutely free. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our boss, Ira Glass. You know, he's instituted this new rule in the office. He gets to take one bite of anyone's lunch. And when I told him that was insane, he got pretty upset.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过750集的档案。再次强调，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心PRX提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们的老板Ira Glass。你知道，他在办公室里实施了一项新规定。他可以咬任何人的午餐一口。当我告诉他那太疯狂时，他很不高兴。
I don't understand why that's so difficult to just, like, hand it over to me.
我不明白为什么仅仅把它交给我这么困难。
I'm Emanuele Berry. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Emanuele Berry。Ira Glass下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。